of course of course Israelites they were
going wrong way actually from from the
bay that we got for showing them and
they made many things awful things that
also other countries
other tribes in the surroundings
God told them to kill babies
any Bible King James ESV Arabic Bible
Chinese Bible all the Bible says the
same thing in Samuel 1 15. I'll read it
for you read the context because
sometimes people think we take out
context so you can read the context all
right okay
where are you from
Algeria
nice to meet you
Samuel
one
two one
Samuel said to Seoul I am the one the
Lord sent anoint you king of his people
Israel so listen now the message from
the Lord this is what the Lord Almighty
says I will punish malachite what they
did to Israel when they were laid them
as they come out from Egypt so this goes
back 500 years before Samuel yeah now go
attack the Malachite and totally destroy
all that they belongs to them do not
spare them put to death men and women
children and infants ketu and sheep
Camus and a donkeys
children babies you know infants you
know it's infants yeah if it's like two
months three months so go say go kill
them because something happened 500
years ago two it is a light
there's other passages too you know
we've got to kill babies
in the war
in the war when there's a war don't kill
man who is innocence don't kill a woman
don't kill children understand when I
Prophet Muhammad heard someone killed
the woman in the world he said why did
you kill her shall not be doing it you
understand but we have the Bible here
on the other side you are also your
example in Islam is also the Abraham and
Abraham he was going actually from this
from this area
yeah yeah it was actually leading also
by going we have the same boat actually
no no I'm not rejecting that but what
I'm saying to you uh because you said I
know the Ten Commandments I don't kill
but I'm just showing you in the Bible
says to kill babies but yes we do
what he said but we have actually the
same
he never believed Jesus to be God and
also let me ask you something you seem a
smart person
is God perfect
god is perfect god is perfect yeah God
knows everything
yes you as a Christian as a Muslim we
know that God knows everything right
okay so if Jesus Is God by therefore he
has to know everything if Jesus Is God
he has to know everything because God
knows everything yeah but in the Bible
in Mark 13 32 Jesus said no one knows
the day and the hour not even the angels
in the Heaven nor the son but only the
father According To Jesus the mighty
messenger We Believe which is the true
Messiah he doesn't know when the day of
judgment is going to happen
so therefore according to you and I will
agree on that God must know everything
Jesus cannot be God because he doesn't
know everything
that he don't know even at this day on
the other side he's because he's obeying
his father about he's also in heaven
vacant cities of his one person if you
say a sport or free
a little different but anyway it is
true sorry I have respect we have to be
honest you know I mean like I just
showed you and you agreed with me that
God knows everything then I showed you
Jesus does not everything
foreign
does God have a god
that's my question does God have a god
no
because God is a good everything yeah
doesn't make any sense go to our God in
the Bible again Jesus said I'm going to
my God and your God so Jesus has a God
and you know what's interesting as well
in the Quran in the Quran in the Quran
Allah Prophet Muhammad they ask about
Dave judgments say no one knows except
Allah so Prophet Jesus and Prophet
Muhammad they said the same thing they
don't know about day of judgments so
that proved they were just prophets of
God they were not good
Jesus said you always got other things
you know it's also Father and father he
was growing and he was saying he is my
belonging son son
baptized
so it's actually connection between them
it's us just uh yeah I believe it's the
prophet
is
very very nice very Chronicles so Jesus
is a God or the son of God
is Jesus God or the Son of God which one
is it
yeah
which one I'm no theologist to explain
foreign it's good yeah oh that's why I'm
doing I'm planting something to think
about it because what I'm speaking about
you don't have to be a scholar I'm
speaking about a simple rational thing
Jesus Is God then no no it's a Son of
God so either is God or Son of God even
Son of God is the son of himself
doesn't make any sense and also let me
tell you something here you know in the
Quran Allah said about Jesus and his
mother both of them used to eat food you
know what it means it means they cannot
be God because God is a self-sufficient
God is not in need of food whose neither
food is the creation God is the creator
that is a logical rational proof in the
Quran why Jesus cannot be God
those are the things that I believe
Jesus we made that he died and he was
arised this I don't know who somebody
managed to say
Jesus dies without without help from
God's things and he was coming on the
earth that he was helping us actually to
understand this love that looks love
the most most thing
those Ten Commandments they are they are
good but actually people is said that
their love is actually the best so it
brings us when we even communicate okay
no doubt about that it's good but we
have to be realistic to ourselves we are
living in the in the universe when there
are some evil people and we have to use
some violence I guess so
because
our dimension
other side is also Satan and we
staying through the different things
are responsible for many things
but God is putting many people those
thoughts might be something people are I
am from European and I know
that he was actually the people as a
tools used to uh and better to speak and
whether on the both side and to to help
good people to kill people
to decide on which side yes
I want to go back about love yeah the
love bit that you mentioned you know to
love is good no doubt to love you but
love is Special Love is special
especially the love of God it's very
special but the Jesus he never came for
love only he never came because in the
Bible in Mark 52 12
52 is a market Jesus said I do you think
I came with peace not at all rather I
came with division
so Jesus said he never came with peace
understand
you go away
everywhere
it's right we are blocking the path okay
we have to give Prophet Muhammad to us
that give a path but I will say to you
quickly look talking about devil all of
that my points here is the Oneness of
God when it comes to Oneness of God
Islamic teaching is simple
is one Allah is a master self-sufficient
let me hear it
there's nothing like unto God when it
comes to Islamic teaching Allah is
perfect he creates us to worship him and
he wants to show us his love his Mercy
his forgiveness but also God will show
us his anger and his mighty for us to
fear Him and to love him and to Hope
for us to love him and to fear Him and
to have hope in him when it comes to
Christianity there's confusion why you
have the father is God correct is the
father fully good your religion is
actually was coming later what was
happened before brother Hinduism is
before Christianity that's not a good
point foreign
foreign
submit to God
according to God's teaching that's right
Abraham was not Jew
it was not Christian
you know it's not Jewish yeah so not
Muslim no he was a Muslim because he
submit to God that's why I mean Muslims
submit to God according to God's
teachings
going afterwards and it was then coming
to Jesus
in the Old Testament there is no Jesus
at all rather in the Old Testament many
things they say
[Music]
this is the difference but uh okay and
the Old Testament says yeah he says
anyone that is crucified is cursed do
you know about the Old Testament anyone
that is hanged on a tree on the cross is
cursed yes so in the Old Testament there
is a light God has been teaching them
that if you've been hanged on a tree or
been hanged on a cross or anything you
are cursed and to be cursed itself is
not good correct all right so now I'm
just coming
so now what happened to Paul who change
the Christianity Paul when he noticed
that if we do believe Jesus was
crucified then we're gonna go and guess
the Bible the Old Testament so what Paul
said Jesus became cursed because of us
so according to Paul Jesus and Satan are
the same because both of them are cursed
but in Islamic teaching Jesus was not
cursed he was a holy person who was a
good person so you should come to Islam
if you really love Jesus because a
Christianity the pool made Jesus to be
cursed
[Music]
actually it was also called he was
telling him to make this offer
afterwards he decide not to make the Sun
by The Sun
if I never killed him he never killed
him he was not here yeah it was a test
to test him to test his belief and to
test his love for God because remember
Abraham he was very old in age when he
had his son so he left it he loved his
son so much you know it's very old and
he has a son so Allah wants to test his
love even Allah knows you know so that
what happened he never killed him and he
gave him a son but what I would say to
you I have respect when you come to
Islam Islam is clear it makes sense
for sure it doesn't make any sense
we know Christians they made bad things
in the history Islam you know also now
it's true there's some bad Muslims bad
Christians no doubt no every Christian
is saying no more but what I'm talking
about here the belief system the Islamic
belief system it goes in line with our
sound reasoning who gave us our sound
reasoning and our natural explanation is
God will you come to Christianity
Christianity go and guess our Sounders
in and our natural Nation so God will
never create us with the tools that go
against his Revelation but Islamic
Revelation from God he goes in line with
God's tools that he created with us god
is perfect in Christianity Let Me Go Old
Testament
does God are great
that's God regrets
you know it's regrets but in this in
this connection I don't know regret me
in like imagine regret when you do
something then you say I wish I never
did it because you don't know that he
didn't know the outcome of it you didn't
know the outcome of it so you regret it
he said that for example for example if
I said to you uh hold my phone yeah then
I go I come back you check my phone I
said I regret giving you my phone
because I didn't know that you would
take my phone are you here
in the Old Testament
God regret he says I greatly regret for
choosing sword as a king so in the Bible
God regrets and regrets when you don't
know the outcome of something that's
deficiency that's why in the Bible
God has been spoken about in a bad way
likewise about the prophet of God
even Allah mentioned it's perfect the
prophets of God in the Quran they are
the best people so you should learn
about Islam you should learn what is
Islam
thank you for discussion thank you very
much
[Music]
from our level of understanding but it's
actually this big big uh encounter on
the how to say
I mean this good and evil yeah and this
is always
everybody needs to be very
seriously nobody can judge the other
sort of other person
yeah
you know there's the best the best way
is actually to have religions always
they have some system and they uh that
is important to the best connection
between because of course not that I I
made myself to God but I say good I'm
open to hear you and to obey your
principles yeah but because each
religion system it is
some Tendencies to move
the best system for the people for the
universe is Islamic system
foreign
is the blood of Jesus yeah that's why
it's allowed for you to drink alcohol in
your in your in your religion no I don't
drink no no I know you don't drink but
it's allowed in the Christianity is
allowed to keep alcoholic not alcoholic
Wine Not alcoholic wine no it's
alcoholic yes yes
um in the pacifist it was Uncle
forbidden no show me
religion
no
no it's not I know it's not but anybody
thinks there are many things
you know do you have any book here to
give you I'm gonna give you something
like you gave me something to eat
but we pray each other
no problem take care of yourself